is our real thoughts on secret of NIMH
too tiny to the rescue oh no oh no no no
no this is one of those sequel cathay I
like the people that asked me to do it
for years cuz they know i love the i'm
gonna warn you now this may be mostly
you can well first up you know about
what he thinks of secret in them and
second i think you know if i remember
this movie then well i'll help you along
uh but i know what you're talking about
cause I saw a no forgettable I thought I
was gonna hate this film even more kinda
than I did but it is another one of
those when I it's like not even worth it
yeah that's kind of feeling it like when
I try to if you were to really think
about the choices they made in this of
course you'd be pissed off and really
angry and stuff but it's one of those
things where I think so the lack of
effort put into it it's clearly they're
not trying to be like hey no no this is
what really happened guy that we know
the original and we love it we're gonna
really try to represent a good sequel to
you it's good ya know it's like now you
know what that films game a little bit
of a following with I think with
Cayetano it's just being bought just
make another sequel for kids or
something yeah use good animations not
the worst honestly is by no means top
blue but for a straight-to-dvd thing
like it back in the late 90s early 2000s
when directive video sequels roamed the
earth
pretty much yeah there were just sequels
to everything I'm so glad we're not I
mean no marijuana a single thing now
it's like this was a weird fucking thing
that just went on forever i oh god i
BLET I didn't i sir started that shit
cuz it wasn't a youngin with the Disney
if it sounds right Disney was doing it
the most and then I started it is yeah
and well what weirds me out is of all
the movies you could do to call up a
sequel for I'm like secret of NIMH
really like it just I felt like I see a
prequel which I hear is what they're
working on now well let me put it this
way like Bambi is a big movie Lion King
big movie then that same secret of NIMH
isn't a big
but it's that sort of movie that you
kind of remember like oh yeah that movie
that that weird movie I saw as a kid and
like this it's not something that I
would have been like sequel yeah like
and in so many years later like that for
what what was that early 80s mmm and so
you're looking at at least 15 year gap
maybe like I forgot when this film came
out well what it feels like to me is
that they probably figured that hey this
is getting a fanbase that they probably
thought was mostly among kids so make
another one for kids when really I think
it's probably more adults that we're
getting into that movie and buying it
want to show it to their kids um
yeah cuz as a kid I really liked secret
name and I knew this was like big and
important but I'm the kid I'm gonna like
my Ninja Turtles and my other stuff I'm
gonna like that boy and I walk on thin
ice here because I think secret of NIMH
is one of the best animated films ever
made like just wait up I know you're
Todd I thought but yeah in a marketing
standpoint why am i guessing and I'm so
that's not to imply that secret of NIMH
is not a movie that's bad I'm just like
why that what the there is nothing in
it's like kind of history and it's
appeal to kids that if I were a studio
executive or like aha I can make a lot
of toys yeah it just it doesn't make any
sense yeah most of characters very
grisly and ugly and easier to make a toy
on this would be like a but you know
it'd be tough because of the way they're
doing be like being in Japan and having
God knows how many animes you could do a
sequel to and them going you know we
need a sequel to spirited away that one
why have one directed DVDs directed to
me yeah like that yeah just how chief
littles like you got even killing you
got full milagres collars now spirited
way to do that way it's like it's such
an atmospheric film on its own it's like
why would you need a said no um but no
so in this everything you can say about
it I mean that really okay I'm not she
not against having another main
character I because I feel like mrs.
Brisby story was so good and she kind of
had her
our canary it's like okay fair enough go
on to the other member of the family
that's a big timonin here's the thing if
you put it on paper and you didn't say
anything about how awful it was gonna be
you just said we're gonna do a sequel to
secret of NIMH it's not gonna be about
miss Pierce people it's gonna be about
her son the one she saved in the first
one yeah why now he saves a bunch of
people I would have been like okay
actually I like her so much for that
movie is dedicated to saving him so now
what's gonna happen for him but there
was a small problem
they really sucked it yeah they really
really sucked at it um and I I'd be
lying if I said you know again just sort
of show the power of the movie cuz when
I did see mrs. Brisby in this film even
though she's not drawing the same in the
making with a little different different
animation stuff there was kind of like
this oh there she it's just weird seeing
her again cuz I so loved that care to
the different ways Acuras yeah not me
keeper with a different voice actress it
was something I was cut it was just kind
of neat seeing her move again and be
animated and it's like a circuit doing
the stories but it was only last a
couple SEC's I'm like oh yeah but it
says as far as a shitty direct-to-dvd
sequel um and it's just one of those
things where it's just the most basic
stop a crazy mad scientist or whatever
from doing something and it did have
that really weird as twist where the
brother takes control gets voiced by
Eric Idle out of nowhere and it's just
suddenly insane it just turned into a
pinky in the brain everything out of
nowhere and it's just something where
it's like the movie is mostly boring up
until that part there there it goes
batshit insane which we were kind of
thankful for yeah like Alicia was good
yeah at least we could have like a funny
reaction to it but everything else was
just so it was every other Mouse
traveling in big world story you know
there just was not that much to it and
and like I said I really have a problem
with anything that builds up big-time
you know especially for a little kid
that you're the chosen one you're gonna
freeze up you're just born great and I
really hate that they feel like we were
getting away from that and then Harry
Potter showed up I'm like fuck yeah it's
like well shit we have this
taury now um which I still haven't read
the blog's I was the one who lived you
the chosen one yeah and then we had the
matrix and then we had the new Star Wars
and yeah but yeah I don't like those
stories you refer to the prophecy the
one who will restore balance to the
force and destroy this French I think I
think I here for the same reason a lot
of people hate princesses it's just it's
the same thing you're just born and
you're great it's like you don't have to
really do anything about say how great
you're going to be a wonderful you're
gonna do I didn't love all this ground I
want to sort it I want to see a story I
would kill to write a story or see a
story where there's a prophecy about
somebody and turns out it's wrong yeah I
know that the prophecy is wrong that
person dies it's actually up to someone
else around them to actually finish what
that person started because the prophecy
you know what fucked up well that's kind
of what I like doing is the books keep
going that's I know what happens that's
it well yeah the religion that gets
brought up around Paul yeah oh no I'll
go to spoilers but that's almost what
happens and that's kind of what happens
I guess in Star Wars but those movies
sucked the vehicles anyway so nobody
remembers that um
but yeah so you have I don't it's it's
mostly forgettable it's mostly a cache
and so it's hard to I don't know it's
hard to get like blood boiling boiling
we angry at it for me the big thing is
just how much they kind of just
disregard mrs. Brisby and I think just
for someone that has so much built-up
around him and then really in the grand
scheme of things does not do much he
goes on a little adventure uh you know
and so a lot of it caused by him and
caused by the nanite event around him
and where mrs. Brisby I mean just came
out of the blue and did all that stuff
and discovered sort of like this secret
to this stone and and you know braved
all these terrible things and because
nobody was telling her hey well you're
you're great you should be able to do
this if anything it was because she was
connected to the other person that was
great improved himself at people are
counting well ok she had to let up in
her husband's shoes is basically what
Hey yeah he was the one with the legend
around him and she only does everything
a lot
maybe she only finds out about it pretty
much after he's dead it seems yeah every
it's like oh your husband Oh your
husband's like oh his sacrifice she's
like oh yeah she doesn't understand she
is still braving all this stuff because
she is so afraid of it but she still
steps in she has a reminder so why to do
it and you know it's just such a fucking
great character and all that danger
feels so real because of her fear but
also because of her bravery of
confronting it in here where she's just
kind of tossed in the movie like that's
the thing I guess if Timmy story had
been all that interesting I would have
forgiven that but to have one of the
greatest but even a fucking statue and
then it's like her statue is over well
yes oh my god nothing it's like what did
this little pipsqueak - it's like he
wasn't even really afraid of anything
and he didn't have to really stand up to
anything he's just started doing we
didn't do it we mouse on an adventure
move he does he didn't really earn it
and then to take what is essentially one
of the greatest single mother characters
it all of animated film has just one I
favor characters in general yeah and to
just toss her aside like as I said had
the head Timmy but an interesting
character could have forgiven it but the
fact that he's not it just makes it so
much more insulting I'm like we have
this perfect character here and then we
just ditch her and then go for this
idiot character like who is just
literally just a stock character out of
every single movie your stock boy
adventurer character and I'm like I
could see any number of animated films
with this character I can see way better
Tom Bluth movies with this character
fucking fucking fifl was a way better
character that Timmy will ever be so
just ah there's something that bothers
me about because I think we we come from
a family of really creative people and
there's something about like all of us
kind of had this understanding where
it's like if we see someone growing up
and they're really creative and really
smart and just like have these you know
but it really present Minds we kind of
know not to glorify it too much or to
not like overdo it because we've I think
in our history we've kind of seen these
things go awry as well I mean not just
family back when people get brony
yeah and then it either builds up too
much pressure or they get too drunk on
the attention and it's one of those
things where when you see
happening in movies where you're gonna
be great you're gonna be fantastic let's
sing songs about you and stuff like that
before you've done anything I just again
I just really look at like would it be
interesting to see people around a
person they're like they don't quite
know how to act like they don't quite
know where they should build this person
up you're Zod and they're trying to
figure it out and there's a little bit
of a mystery to it or something like
that you know instead of just you're
great you're phenomenal you're the one
you're the chosen one I mean would it be
great if it was like more of a secret
and they're trying to figure it on the
trying to see that's what I fucking like
about Ender's Game I know a lot of
people did like that movie and I didn't
read the book so you're probably right
did you know the books probably better
but the book is better I'll save you but
but that that's what I liked about that
movie is that they didn't know and they
were just like let's just see what we
can find out let's see where this would
lead and I like the way that kid played
it uh and I thought that's thousand an
example of that of kinda like the semi
chosen one done right in my opinion like
that's always how I want to disagree and
I think I think finally I I've got a
comparison you know this is you have
Terminator where we have Linda Hamilton
you know going through the whole movie
and she does this really interesting
character now imagine if they did
Terminator 2 and frickin John Connor
shows up Eddie furlong
like saves Sarah Connor there and is
like well bye mom and then it's just
about his dorky adventure and you know
feel wrong that's what this movie feels
like and and then not only that but his
adventures with the Terminator sock like
that's what this movie is is like if you
took something like fun that expands on
whatever the original would have had and
just removed anything that made it good
anything you know so fast you brought
that up about Terminator Kazanjian I
never thought Sarah Connor was
interesting the first moment I just
thought the second one is where she got
interesting oh that's far the point she
even gets more interesting I thought she
was interesting enough in the first
movie I mean she's not lying bad or
terrible or anything about it's just
kind of like you know yeah
okay we'll go up against Arnold
Schwarzenegger as an unkillable robot
but I I have to say I think a lot of it
even oh shit what Michael Biehn is that
the guy that goes back at time the first
yeah yeah even he's got the same thing
no you don't care do you he's empty no
why doesn't anyone believe me you what
it's it but I I wish you send all I love
your hate mail no I love that movie
it's wishes a smile city we should just
write the be a story ashildr crow no I
actually do really enjoy that movie but
I mean it's I don't think she's with it
lights no idea Terminator Genisys okay
anyone open cares for you just
completely shit on a wonderful property
hey Turner Jessie's did that already I
anyway that is just my point you have a
character like Sarah Connor and that
imagine doing a sequel where basically
she shows up for five minutes does
nothing and it's all about our idiot kid
who basically is really uninteresting to
watch doesn't do much of anything and by
the end of movie like why do I waste two
hours watching this kid like yeah that
would have been scary man that would
have been the Timmy's adventure
Terminator 2 that is what that movies
like you know what been cool for the
statue thing cuz that is the one thing
that just pissed me off like they they
really fucking build a statue of him
next to you know the the father and
everything if they had the Statue of the
Father and then when Timmy's arriving
there they just put up the statue of
mrs. Brisby and then when he goes on his
stupid little adventure and actually
does something you know I have to write
that in but does something of actual
risk and worth and stuff like that uh
then they put the the statue of him up
there um cuz then they can be there as
like a whole families too but when it's
just the father in just the son be like
Mary Joseph in Jesus maybe I don't know
he likes anonymity I mean no even even
like the statue of him as a kid is not
fair because again it's building up all
this stuff that's like he's never gonna
be able to amount to it's just I don't
like that I don't do it I mean this is
why so many child actors you know it
turned out so screwed up and stuff
because they're just exposed to this
world where they're just glorified and
then forgotten and they get used to the
attention in this really messed up
environment
and it's like it's not healthy you know
and I really resist one thing only do
the people it's even more when they do
it to kids in these stories and I just
think that's just not fair it's not
healthy poochy we have just like TMZ
yeah little stray bags so um I think
that's about it and I'm trying to think
of anything else to every I know is
really fun as something he's the best
thing in it but he put it but that's the
thing he belong that that's a different
movie like that's the weird thing about
it is like it it's it's three competing
films you got something remotely
resembling secret of them that they dump
almost instantly you've got this just
crappy kids adventure then you have
whatever movie Eric Idle is in yeah so
he's great but it's just he's great
because he so just just put the fuck
yeah um no this has blue seen this film
ha ha ha I'm sure he must own curious if
he's ever said anything about it like
honestly if I be guess my thought would
be just beep Oh direct-to-dvd yet ok
honestly yeah it worth it if I weren't
kidding if I don't if I were double if I
probably wouldn't even bothered to watch
it uh I mean if he has honestly I would
have been like Gillian I I know we like
where's Larry there's not a William
Friedkin I think said he never saw any
of the exorcist sequels which you should
see three I was gonna say in one respect
it's sad because I actually think the
third one's pretty good but I I think he
was talking about two in particular I'm
like I don't blame him yeah like like no
haven't seen it then when it seems fair
yeah so um but yeah that's that's about
it I like a side of NIM oh yeah and then
watch our review of secret of NIMH - yes
I don't think don't bother getting a
film um there's yeah there's really no
point it's not even so bad it's like
angry door so bad as I would a video
Eric Idle yeah uh that's the only thing
where it's like okay now this is kind of
fun for how batshit crazy it is uh but
yeah it's one of those things where it's
like it's pretty definitely a skip so
that's about it and we'll see it the
next one later